people need to start feeling
confident not only about the vaccine but
about the ethical practices
of medicine in relation to our community
if one particular community remains
unvaccinated then the virus will seek
them out and will go through that
community like wildfire there is much
more vaccine hesitancy among
some of our black asian and other ethnic
minority communities
i'm planning for our family in future
and the rumors saying that
it can affect your fertility you
feel restless after taking this
vaccine when you are invited by the nhs
or your gp
to go for your jobs do not hesitate
[Music]
a very good evening and welcome to a sky
news special program
on vaccine hesitancy the first phase of
the vaccine rollout
is now complete more than 15 million
people in the uk
have now been vaccinated and the
government says that the job has been
offered to everyone in the first
four most vulnerable groups but in some
black asian and minority ethnic
communities the take-up has been low
the chief executive of the nhs simon
stevens tonight described it
as a pandemic of misinformation which is
fueling vaccine hesitancy
well tonight we'll discuss those
concerns and look at what needs to be
done to help
people feel more confident about the
vaccines
i'll be joined by a panel of experts and
we'll be putting some of your questions
to them but first
sky's correspondent national horinak has
been speaking to people in bame
communities when you are invited
by the nhs or your gp to go
for your jobs do not hesitate sermons
come with a message of reassurance at
this mosque in birmingham as next door
another prayer room operates as a
vaccination center
this was the uk's first mosque to offer
the jabs it's doing hundreds a day
but it sits in a city where in some
areas nearly half of people
are declining the vaccine over unproven
fears
with a lot of other things you know will
it affect my fertility
um you know if i have the vaccine will
somebody track me
um so there's a lot of mistrust about it
hesitancy is highest among black
pakistani and indian people
despite these ethnicities being more
likely to die from covert 19.
in newam in london despite cases here at
one stage being the highest in the
country
rumors have led to anxiety i'm planning
for a family in future and the rumor
saying that that
it can affect your fertility so
that's the main factor and apart from
that many other factors because we
it's just been like a month people
having vaccine
so the outcomes will take time
i heard um you feel restless
after taking this vaccine if someone
told you
that wasn't true it's it's okay to take
it would that change your mind
yeah if so
if said doctor said yeah this skepticism
is a national concern but those getting
their vaccines in birmingham
are ignoring the misinformation i did
not listen to anybody else or the
community groups
you get so many messages in whatsapp and
all that
i never listened to it because i'm
listed extremely vulnerable
i thought whenever i get my chance i'll
you know go and have it
if nhs are spending so much money in uk
our duty is to take the injection
and support them because nhs are
looking after us the question has always
been why does this vaccine skepticism
exist why the reluctance and resistance
to have this jab well all the
communities are different but some of
the issues they have in common
include believing myths and historical
misbeliefs
that have been fueled by what people are
watching and listening to
on these this vaccine is experimental on
the human race
social media videos containing
disturbing and false
information have spread within some
communities
rev says for many they have exacerbated
mistrust
that stems from a long legacy of medical
mistreatment
we found that the black community has
had a
disproportionate experience around
experimentation of
medicine on our community so people need
to start feeling
confident not only about the vaccine but
about the
ethical practices of medicine in
relation to our community i think
you would recall there was even a friend
two french scientists
who have alluded to the fact that it's
all right to test some vulnerable parts
of africa
where we might they might get a bit more
experimental opportunities
that should not happen those in the nhs
acknowledge there is no quick fix to
heal the anxiety
but covert 19 doesn't give them the
luxury of time
it's definitely low trust amongst the
ethnic minority communities that we need
to look at
and that may well be historical but it's
not just about a decision
of whether you're going to take a
vaccine or not there's wider
implications here
it's about protecting the health of your
loved ones community leaders say more
education is needed to encourage the
fearful
a vaccine milestone may have been
reached but there are many more miles of
confidence building ahead
to ensure slaves of society aren't left
vulnerable
and ash is now here with me in the
studio to discuss
her report in a moment or two but i'm
also joined by
dr zubaida hack a member of the
independent sage and former interim
director at the ronnie b
trust we've also got helen donovan
professional lead for public health
at the royal college of nursing with a
specialism in vaccinations
and imam khari azeem the chair of
mosques and
imams national advisory board from leeds
moscow a very good evening
to you all and i'd like to kick off with
you dr hack and
we'll get into some of the the reasons
the wise and where force for this
vaccine hesitancy
in a moment or two but just tell me your
overall concerns about these statistics
these findings
a successful vaccination program will
not be successful
if it's undermined by low vaccine uptake
and essentially this is
this is the nub of the issue here which
is that we have
low vaccine or evidence of low vaccine
uptake
not only among black and ethnic minority
people
minority communities but also among
deprived communities and also among
eastern europeans we know vaccine
hesitancy issues
exist um more in women than men more in
younger people and so on
so my biggest concern here is not that
it's just an
issue specific to particular ethnic
minority communities
which by the way is important because we
know that black and i think minority
communities and people from deprived
areas
have been much more vulnerable to severe
covet illness
as well as mortality from covid19
that's important but vaccine hesitancy
is clearly an
issue across different communities and
in that sense we need to address it
because at some point
what's a marginal issue or if you like
an issue on the side at the moment
can tip into the mainstream okay uh your
opening thoughts
let let me get um your sense of what do
you
hear within the community about vaccine
hesitancy
why do people who don't want to take the
vaccine why do they say they think that
i think there are wide and varied
reasons for hesitancy in taking a
vaccine
and as we're the hub says it's not just
the black asian minority ethnic
communities but
there are other minority communities or
marginalized communities that also
are showing hesitancy and i'd also like
to explore whether it's hesitancy like i
not want to take the vaccine or
it's just a cautious approach at this at
this moment in time
there are also intergenerational issues
uh having
i've been holding webinars across the
country with
muslim communities and also other
communities and what i find
is that an elderly generation they have
slightly different reasons for their
hesitancy
to some of the young people with young
people
it may be more lack of trust or
also um micro nano chip issues whereas
with the
elderly generation is more to do with
side effects
and what impact vaccine will have on us
and helen donovan just uh underline for
us your concerns and why
this matters because some people are
going to say i thought vaccination
was a matter of personal choice it's
it's up to me
it is a matter of personal choice but
it's really important as both the other
panelists have said
that we have a really high rate of
uptake across
all of the community and and i would
absolutely agree
with the the sense that diamond has just
said
about vaccine hesitancy and exploring
some of that because
asking questions about a vaccine or any
treatment is isn't uh unusual and it's
not wrong
and we should be expecting people to ask
questions
and i think one of what we need to be
able to do is get to communities and be
able to answer those questions
because it's absolutely right that
different people will have different
fears it might be
because they're worried that the
vaccines have been tested so quickly and
we should be able to address that
or as one of the ladies on the video
clip that you showed
about fertility and we can and dispel
those myths and i think as she also said
if she has that explanation from a
healthcare professional
and who's able to dispel those myths
people by and large do
trust that information but it's about us
being able to get into those communities
and be able to give that information in
the way that people need it
well thank you all very much indeed for
your opening comments we're going to be
drilling down into
some of those issues much more deeply in
the next 45 minutes or so and also we're
taking some questions from sky news
viewers but uh i want to bring in asher
in a moment but
first let's take a closer look at some
of the data that she's uncovered in a
study of over 11 000 uk adults get this
82 percent said they would likely or
very likely have a covet 19 vaccine but
this figure
changes very dramatically for solely
black or
black british adults with nearly 72
percent stating that they were
unlikely stroke very unlikely to be
vaccinated
and pakistani bangladeshi adults are 42
unlikely slash very unlikely to be
vaccinated and as i say uh
ashna joins me now we're taking that
survey in with your report so i mean
we're all very concerned about this
aren't we just tell us
some of the voices some of the people
you spoke to what they were saying it's
really interesting derek because
the reason why this is newsworthy the
reason why it's interesting is because
we know that these communities
are disproportionately affected by this
virus and yet you've still got members
of that those communities
who are fearful and it's interesting
that some of the myths
are um share some similarities even
though these people are from various
different communities
you've got myths surrounding the
ingredients you've got myths surrounding
the side effects
but all of these appear to be built upon
some deep-seated multi-generational
uh fears and reservations that some
people have to do with trust to do with
authority
and that's not just across the board
that's particular towards the black
community for instance but one thing
that's interesting is that
anti-vaxxers are really um i guess
playing on this concept
they we have seen this rise and
disinformation in in
in rising fears especially on online
platforms and i think that's why you've
seen today
the chief executive of the nhs
assignment stephen's addressing
that we are tackling two pandemics we're
tackling the actual virus itself but
we're also
tackling the virus the pandemic of
misinformation
and that's what we're going to tackle
over the course of this next hour or so
ashna for the time being thank you very
much indeed as i say
we've got some questions been sent in by
sky news viewers let's uh address one of
them now this is from
amy day thomas who asks black and
asian participants in the vaccine trials
are reported to be
comparatively low was there any
indication that the vaccines might work
differently
in these ethnic groups given that for a
variety of reasons their covert 19
morbidity and mortality rates are worse
than other
groups uh good question immediately we
might have uh
not have time to get around to all our
panelists but uh let me ask you
helen donovan the trials would they
address emi day's concerns
so we know from the trial data that
there was a very
broad um group of wide ethnic minority
groups were tested and the trials were
done
in various different countries um
obviously we're looking
at you know relatively small numbers in
comparison to
to the now roll out of the vaccine
program but
the the evidence is that it was tested
along
you know a very very wide group of
people so
i think we can assure um people that
that actually
there was good trial data across all
ethnic minority groups
um that have been tested and no evidence
that
um the vaccine worked any less
effectively in different groups so i
think yes we can assure people on that
okay and and dr hack overall let me add
in that
a lot of people from all communities
also noticed how quickly these vaccines
have been developed and some people
saying well
can they really be safe with that amount
of speed behind them
scientific feat how quickly it was
developed but i think what's important
to acknowledge
is the amount of money that was put into
this the reason
it was developed so quickly is because
of the sheer
political force the sheer resource
that's been put in and normally vaccine
trials are much slower because they
don't have that
political backup they don't have that
resource they have to go through lots
and lots of different committees and so
on and all of that was escalated
i want to go back to your original
question that you asked helen which uh
which was around
different ethnic groups being involved
in these trials i think it's really
important for people to know that black
and ethnic minority groups were involved
in the trials but
also there's no one gene for being asian
there's no one gene for being
black so you know to expect that that
trials can take into account black black
and ethnic people in in that way is is
ridiculous
what we need to do what needs to happen
is for trials to take into account
all sorts of different backgrounds
different bodies
different more different comorbidities
and so on and that's what these trials
have done
the other thing i want to say very
quickly is we keep coming back to the
same point around
misinformation and misperceptions and
it's really really important to say one
thing
which is that the only way to counter
misperceptions and to counter
misinformation
is for the government to set up a
website because the government
needs to be the government are trusted
but to set up a website
a trusted website which has accurate
up-to-date information about the vaccine
about vaccine rollout
about who's taking it about who's not
taking it so that
everybody everybody in the country has a
single source of information
and at the moment we're not seeing that
from this government
and uh ash now that is the point isn't
it that uh misinformation you came
across it
it's everywhere and it's transmitted in
so many different fashions
so many different ways i mean social
media we know is
a tool that can be useful but it also
can be quite dangerous and that's what's
certainly
something that we're seeing especially
with the the older communities the older
people
who are not sure where this information
has come from they're saying it's
potentially from a medical professional
and they're believing it because on the
face of it that's where it says it comes
from
and uh imam azeem just specifically
on that question that the the trials
were not particularly aimed at so or
didn't deal
enough with concerns within one
community have you heard
that any of those kind of voices
absolutely yes i have come across and
that that premise uh also the fact that
um
uh i think the fact that there were less
people volunteering for
uh the trials also goes to show that
there is perhaps
mistrust among certain members of the
communities
uh which has led to which has continued
to
reinforce the point that people do not
trust the um
the source and but having said all of
that i think it's important
that the the trials that the
assessments that took place did include
people of all backgrounds
and we are confident about the safety
of the vaccine and from religious
perspective
you know i can say that we as imams and
scholars
have consulted with medical
professionals and
others and we are confident not only
about the safety and efficacy
of the vaccines but also that there
should be no religious hesitation
in taking the vaccine the the mistrust
exists but we need to have
trusted individuals as well as
organizations institutions involved in
delivering the message
in a culturally sensitive and and
delivered in a way which people can
relate to and that's why where you see
vaccination centers being opened in
community centers or
mosques or places of worship has
actually boosted people's confidence to
take the vaccines
okay hold those thoughts because we're
going to have a short break coming up on
this sky news special programme
we're going to be discussing more about
the health concerns
among ba e community states
we want to take a further look at some
of the reasons why people from black
asian and minority ethnic communities
could be hesitant about the vaccine
program
now in a recent office for national
statistics survey almost
two-thirds of adults from an ethnic
minority background who said they were
unlikely to get a job said they were
worried about potential side effects
now that's compared to 45 percent of
adults of
white ethnic background well uh before i
speak
to the panel about that let's just hear
all that issue from
mashkura in birmingham i'd like to ask
as a muslim woman
would it be suitable for me to use the
vaccine in terms of the ingredients it
contains
is it halal would it be suitable for
those of muslim background
well imam assim that's a very
specific question from ashkura again it
must be something
you hear quite often i'm sure it's uh
asking as a muslim woman would it be
suitable for me to use
in terms of the ingredients it contains
is
the vaccine hello
yeah absolutely the scholars in the uk
and abroad have confirmed
that the vaccines
used in the uk do not contain any
animal product or human embryo it does
not contain
gelatin or alcohol and as a result
the vaccines are absolutely halal they
are permissible under islamic law
in fact many imams have been actually
making videos of themselves being
vaccinated
to reassure communities and inspire
confidence in people
that the vaccines use are absolutely
halal
there should be no religious hesitation
no hegestation from religious
perspective
not to take the vaccine and dr hack just
underlined that for us the the
ingredients of these vaccines they've
been
developed by different routes but just
underlined for us that they are all
very very very i can't get enough varies
in their safe
as far as we know as far as the data
shows that the
amount all the ingredients are compliant
with the dietary requirements of most of
their faith groups
um but i think just to go beyond that
i think i want to go back to something
that helen said earlier which is we have
to recognize
that this isn't just about myths and
misperceptions
or irrational ones from groups what we
know from vaccine hesitancy research is
actually
it's a really diverse set of concerns
and anxieties
most of which are very legitimate
anxieties to have anxieties about
fertility
to have anxieties about side effects
particularly when you've been
among groups that have been have been
very vulnerable to kovic 19 when you've
looked around and you've seen
more people from your community going
into hospital being hospitalized with
covert 19
dying from coping 19 i think these are
really rational questions to ask
hang on will these vaccines will these
vaccines have side effects that would be
very detrimental to me
are they being rolled out too fast you
know what's in them
will it affect my fertility and so on an
independent sage we have meetings
for public meetings every friday we've
heard these concerns from
all from all sections of society
which is why once again i want to go
back to the fact that
in order to address these fears there
will be lots of different ways of
addressing it
but it's not just about working with
faith communities and community groups
although that's very very important it's
also about having a
national website about the government
leading
this public health messaging and and
awareness raising campaign working with
local
trusted public health professionals and
providers
as well as faith groups and community
groups in order to reach these
communities
and finally i want to raise another
point which is vaccine hesitancy
is also about access and we need to
address
issues around access whether people have
the transport
whether they can afford to take some
time off to get the vaccine and so on
so we need that comprehensive if you
like communication strategy
as well as research to find out what
that vaccine hesitancy is about
okay and some of those points we're
going to return to at the end
of this hour but uh another question
another thoughts
are coming from one of our viewers this
from toby aguirre who asks
are the side effects of taking these
vaccines different
for say an ethnic person than their
white counterparts so
overall it's it's about side effects
i mean are there any side effects sub
whatever nationality or ethnicity
you come from what do you think about
that helen donovan
i think has been said before i mean
there's no reason to think that any
particular ethnic group
is going to suffer side effects over and
above anybody else but i think
you know going back to the points that
have been raised from zabaida
and and iman iman
it's about being able to address those
particular concerns and we know from all
vaccine programs that the first thing
that people will ask
is is this vaccine safe um and within
that
what are the expected side effects so
explaining to people
um what the side effects are likely to
be
is really really important and there are
uh
leaflets and information and videos
available on the nhs websites and on the
public health
websites and i think one of the things
for
for me particularly from from a nursing
perspective
is making sure that my nursing
colleagues and others
have access to that information so that
they're able to disseminate it to
people because you know going back to
what i said before it's absolutely
bright and you know understandable that
people will have these questions
but i think in terms of what whether
certain people will have
more side effects there isn't any
evidence from any of the data that we've
got
that would suggest that there is um
and we can be assured of the safety of
these vaccines
and their efficacy in preventing severe
disease which again
has been said has particularly affected
the black and asian minority
groups um you know exponentially in this
with kobit 19 so it's really really
important that we get those messages
over
okay let's get some more messages over
so many questions coming in this one
from esther from london uh this one on
video let's have a listen to esther
i'm at the age where i'm considering
fertility
is this vaccine safe for me with
statistics around
the lack of care black women like myself
have had with the nhs black women being
five times more likely to die at
childbirth compared to their white
counterparts
how will people like myself to trust and
believe
the vaccine which has been administered
by the nhs
okay well that's a very good question
from esther i'm sure dr hack
you'll agree would would you like to put
esther's mind at rest because of course
the vaccine was was not tested on on
pregnant women at all was it
no but i think one of the vaccines and
forgive me i can't remember which one
has um now said that it is more it's it
is
um safer for um for women who are trying
to get pregnant but
yes no it hasn't been tested and i think
esther's absolutely right to be
nervous and and to have some anxiety
because we know for instance that
black women black women have been five
times more likely to
die from childbirth um you know
childbirth in this country and very
little has been to address that
very little has been done to address
that and that's quite an important issue
around vaccine hesitancy because these
are you know lived experiences of black
and ethnic minority communities in this
country
where they feel they have been failed by
health providers by health services by
the government and we don't have to look
very far back
to see that you know that that's one of
the reasons why black and ethnic
minority groups are disproportionately
dying
um with covet 19 in this country but i
think once again
we have to go back once again this is
something that the government
needs to address and working with
working with the
working with the pharmaceutical
companies working with health providers
working with nhs public health
professionals to share that information
um and i think right now it you know
it's important to
watch that information and um to have
the government lead the way on this
and actually just very quickly i mean
we're halfway through this this hour so
just uh i i see you
nodding each and every question that
comes in i mean this
is precisely what you've been coming
across during the course of your
reporting on this issue
yes it is interesting to hear all of
those guests talk about those issues
because they're very real
and they're legitimate concerns when
you're talking to people and you're
asking them okay
what's making you nervous about this
vaccination and they're always hesitant
to even tell you
because they're slightly embarrassed by
it but they are also
they're very real concerns to them they
don't want you don't want to be laughing
at them when they're telling you
what their what they're hearing um i
think it's really interesting that
a surgery i heard from today only in
luton said a 100
of their patients who were black either
review refused to have the vaccine
or said that they haven't decided
whether they want it yet that's
a surgery every single black person
that have been offered the vaccines got
a caveat of that okay
um well let me put that to you uh from
um
from esther uh helen donovan i mean it
is quite damning that
um on the nhs black women uh five times
more likely to die at childbirth
compared to their white counterparts
how are people like me she said to trust
and believe the vaccine
that is being administered by the nhs
yeah i i think this it goes to the crux
of it doesn't it really because
um when you have a minority or minority
groups
who don't feel that the services um are
for them and they don't recognize the
services of being able to deliver
care for them um then we've got you know
these are going to be a long
process to to to get that information
to make information out to them and i
think that one of the things that we
know from other vaccine programs
is that it isn't just about the national
information
it's about giving people the opportunity
to ask those questions on an individual
basis
and as again some of your survey
respondents said
having that information from a
healthcare professional is really
powerful and we know that from other
vaccine programs
so what i think we will need to do is to
give people the opportunity to
speak to somebody so calling up people
that haven't responded to vaccines and
actually going through their fears with
them and going through their questions
with them will be really important and
is really important
um to make them see that that is you
know the service is for them
and i think the other thing that came
out is having um
vaccine clinics in mosques in churches
in other places in community centers and
seeing community leaders
proporting the vaccine and encouraging
the vaccine is really important as well
so i think it needs all of those factors
well it's been really important talking
to you thank you uh to my panel we're
saying goodbye now to dr zubaida hack
and helen donovan but it's not over yet
because coming up after the break
we'll discuss some of those conspiracy
theories we've been talking about
circulating around these coveted
vaccines and the role of social media
much more on that
and i'll be joined by two new panelists
including
the clinical researcher with the oxford
vaccine group
stay with us now i want to
introduce our new panel to you now uh dr
faith you arde an immunologist
with the francis crick institute dr
mahesh ramaswamy
a senior clinical researcher at the
oxford vaccine group
and consultant physician at oxford
university hospitals
nhs foundation trust and staying with us
is
imam khari azeem the chair mosques and
imams national advisory board and chair
of leeds mosque very good to see you all
and still an awful lot to get through
because in this section we'll be
discussing misinformation and
theories that could be contributing to
vaccine hesitancy also the role of
technology and of course social media
in the spreading of that misinformation
well let's start with our
new panelists and you doctor yuarde
i mean there are broadly some pretty
wild
theories out there about these vaccines
yeah there's quite quite a lot of
misinformation
circulating around all around the
community um
a lot via social media a lot via
whatsapp and messaging
fit people have real fears about the
vaccine may be altering their dna or
um a 5g micro 5g and microchipping
it's quite a lot of misinformation
spreading around yeah
yeah i mean you mentioned the role of
social media
in that i mean is it is it small groups
or
some of those theories we've all come
across some of them are widespread right
across the globe almost
yeah i think it's it's a it's a mixture
some of it is
smaller groups but um some of it is just
stuff that's been forwarded or shared
quite readily from friends
um or there's big conspiracy theories um
that you're seeing that are just
spreading amongst the community really
really easily
um i think it's just a mixture of small
and
big things but the idea is once people
latch on to a conspiracy theory
they seem to latch on to quite a few
more but how strongly held are
some of the beliefs i mean you mentioned
for instance let's let's pick one the
the altering of people's dna
and some of that i mean following the
way that developed it's because some of
the vaccines are coming through that
mrna route are people just just getting
confused
yeah i think the root of that initially
exactly what you said it's the idea that
people hear
rna and they think that's very closely
related to dna and they think
that must be altering my dna in some
form or
way um but these conspiracy theories
they often take
a spread of a bit of information and it
can be a little bit of misunderstanding
of the science sometimes
that can embed these theories and i
think people who have these ideas they
sometimes can be quite um
strongly head held but for some people
they've just heard that misinformation
and they haven't heard the real facts so
that's the main bit of information that
they're getting
so it's just about filling that with
real and correct information and then
generally they'll
change their mind or at least do some
further research on it
and uh dr ramasama you come in on this
and
and i know um you just joined us but you
overheard our previous conversation
uh you're in a position to tell us a
little bit more about um let's start
with that about some
the effect of vaccines on pregnant women
or those who wish to become so
that's right and that's a question i get
asked quite a lot by my patients
um you know is our vaccine safe in
people who are planning pregnancy or
people who are pregnant
now the two vaccines that are available
in the uk are the mrna fisa vaccine
and the viral vectored oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
neither is it of those vaccines can
cause covid19 disease
both of those vaccines are safe
in people are
are safe in people whose immune systems
don't work very well
we worry in pregnancy because we at the
moment
don't have enough data of people who've
received the vaccine in pregnancy
and that's because in the clinical
trials we
don't normally recruit people in early
clinical trials who are planning to get
pregnant or who are pregnant themselves
and that's just
routine procedure but there's no reason
given that these
vaccines can't in themselves cause
disease that it would cause any
that would be likely to cause any
problem either to the pregnant woman or
to their baby
so the guidance now in the uk is that if
somebody is at risk of contracting
covert 19
infection for example if they're a
health care worker and are
occupationally at risk
or if they have another health care
condition that
means that they are otherwise at risk of
severe cover disease such as heart
disease or lung disease
then they can be vaccinated but it's an
individual decision so someone who's
planning to get pregnant or who is
pregnant should talk to their gp talk to
their health care practitioner about
what's the right thing for them and
weigh up those risks and benefits for
themselves well thanks for clearing that
up and just let me underline to our
audience where that's come from uh the
senior clinical researcher with the
oxford vaccine group so you know all
about that
uh tell me about though um dr amusami
your concerns and and are they deep
concerns
about the level in some communities of
misinformation about the vaccines
yes it's it's really um dispiriting to
hear that
um people from ethnic minority groups
are not taking up the vaccine
you know as the clinician that's who i
see coming into
into my hospital with bad covert you
know people who are elderly
people from ethnic minorities and people
with with co-morbidities
and to me it just seems really
frustrating that people who are
at the most at risk are not accepting a
vaccine that's safe
and effective that would protect them
that would stop them from getting this
severe disease in the first place
and uh imam curry has seen i mean we've
got to look at this information
misinformation it
it's not as if it's in isolation this is
part of a
a wider distrust in illustrated in
in so many ways so many different ways
and overall distrust of of authority
figures of authority organizations the
idea that somewhere there's a hidden
agenda
well um as chair of marston imam's
national advisory board we've been
holding
webinars across the country and trying
to hear people's concerns be
trying to listen to those concerns and
then respond to them
in a way that people can relate to so
some of the things that we come across
uh include structural and health
inequalities
uh in particular amongst young people
there is
greater lack of trust and mistrust of
authorities
a lack of meaningful engagement between
public institutions
and grassroots is also another cause for
this lack of trust amongst young people
and so a combination of vulnerability
and distrust of those in authority
manifests
itself in defensiveness and just to
highlight that
by the way of an example i was mediating
a particular family scenario where
father had been lost
to kovid 19 sadly mother elderly mother
really obviously wanted to protect her
life and take the vaccine but
one of her sons was quite into the 5g
radiation and some of the misinformation
and so it took a while to talk to the
family
trying to help the young person make an
informed choice
because misinformation in this pandemic
can cost lives and i think we all need
to
understand that the people are not
hesitant to protect life or expose
themselves
or others to risk but there are
underlying reasons
why some people are hesitant and we need
to work with those communities
well let me talk about you talk about
costing lives about specific locations
where it could cost
lives where lives are attempting to be
being saved doctor
you are and i'm talking here about nhs
hospitals
about care homes and a disproportionate
number of ethnic minority people
work in these locations and if they're
turning down the vaccines
how concerned are you about that
yeah as you can imagine i'm pretty
concerned about it
like you said we're disproportionately
affected so you'd hope that we would be
the first people rushing to take the
vaccine but it's like
um what was said before it's that
mistrust and it's that worry that makes
people
to to worry about whether or not they
should actually take it and set
and makes them stop and think before
they make that decision i mean
personally i think that i would like as
many people to take
take up the opportunity for me both my
parents have now had their
first dose and i'm more than happy and
i'm really excited for them to know that
they are now
at least somewhat protected from this um
horrible disease
but of course i'm really really
concerned in the way that i'm sure that
most
people who are scientists or clinicians
are worried about the fact that you know
we need to move past this pandemic and
one of the ways to do that
is with vaccination and we need to
vaccinate people who are most vulnerable
and today we're talking about those
people who are vulnerable because of um
their background such as ethnic
minorities and dr ramasamy just on that
specific point about
locations where people where sections of
the people who work there
are turning down vaccines and talking
about nhs hospitals
and care homes where of course the vast
majority of deaths occur
this is a real concern
that's right it's a concern um partly
because
um many people contract kovid within
these settings so people come into
hospital with something else and they
catch covered in hospital
and that you know could be from related
to health care workers transmitting
infections unknowingly
and the same in care homes and but also
you know health care workers are trusted
members of communities people look up to
them
and look to them for advice and if they
are hesitant to take up the vaccine then
that makes it very difficult to promote
good messages
in communities okay uh stay with us
another break coming up
but after that we'll be talking about
the possible solutions and how the
government and community leaders
hope to tackle this misinformation stay
with us
now in the final part of tonight's
special program we would like to discuss
what perhaps can be done to try to
increase the uptake of
vaccines by black asian and minority
ethnic groups
in today's downing street news
conference the nhs
chief executive simon stevens call it a
jewel epidemic
a pandemic of misinformation and of
course a virus pandemic
there is a huge effort involving
community leaders faith leaders
the way in which the nhs itself is
administering the vaccine program
to overcome that and although the start
was slower in terms of the uptake in
some of those communities i think we are
now seeing
meaningful progress part of what we're
up against is a
dual epidemic we're up against the uh
epidemic the pandemic of covid
and we're up against a pandemic of
disinformation and the deliberately
sowing of mistrust the deliberate sowing
of mistrust a pandemic of misinformation
no well imam khali azim you've been
talking to us throughout the course
of this hour what you're doing
personally to try to counter this
misinformation but of course
that's not enough what more do you
think or do you feel if you do feel the
government should be doing
i think sometimes we talk about that
there are communities who are hard to
reach
but it's not that they are hard to reach
but we need to reach them in a way
that's that's amicable and culturally
sensitive
as well as a culturally tailored message
in this pandemic the messenger is as
important as the message itself
but through the work that menard has
done we've seen
that actually the tide is turning the
people who are hesitant
at the beginning you know in our
communities by
opening the vaccination centers in
mosques by
delivering sermons during friday prayers
to the members of the muslim
congregation
as well as holding a
webinars with those communities we are
seeing
that actually people people are
overcoming their hesitancy
and so if if there's communication issue
or access issues we can have vaccination
buses
to those communities where people
perhaps
will be reluctant to go to if there's
vaccination center further away
so there's a lot that can be done but i
think in this in this pandemic
the messenger is really important as
well as
reaching those communities and
alleviating their concerns rather than
dismissing those concerns
it's uh dr ramazani that's an important
point isn't it because if
the messenger aka the government is
mistrusted
it's more important than that the
message comes across
from those that are trusted and they
very often are those
closer to the ground they're amongst the
communities
i think that's right there are um
several
government websites so the nhs website
for example which has lots of
information about vaccine safety
but i think if there is mistrust in
um the system in the government then
perhaps those aren't the places people
are going to look for
independent trustable sources of
information
so i think what we're what we need are
we need individuals to stand up we need
healthcare workers to stand up
we need community leaders to stand up it
might even be as simple as having
experts that
look like you those are the people that
peop that individuals and communities
will believe in but it's also having the
right forum
it's not having lectures or websites or
talks
what people really need is an
opportunity to be able to put forward
questions and
to be able to have those answered
honestly and accurately and without any
any vaccine shaming you know without any
judgment or
um without any uh judgmental views
that's really important and that's
difficult to to
achieve on a large scale and your
thoughts on that uh dr yuarde i mean if
the
if the government is perceived rightly
or wrongly to be
the source of many problems wider
problems within a community it's not
then necessarily the source to shoot
down
some of this misinformation where do you
think it would best come from
yeah no i agree with what other people
on the panel have said it's about
coming from a trusted voice and the
government isn't necessarily the source
that you'll look to
so it's generally coming from someone
who's close by it could be a family
member
like for example myself um as a
scientist i've spoken to many people who
went close to friends and family
about the vaccine and why it's safe and
i think because people trust my opinion
and they know
that i know what i'm talking about it's
a good source of information but even if
you don't have a scientist nearby
or close to you in that same way there
are people on social media working
towards making sure that people can get
access
to um good sources of information so for
example i'm part of a group called team
halo
and it's a group of scientists who work
on coping 19 but also other scientists
and they're just trying to communicate
good information and we're doing it by
the form of
tick-tock and that's one of the ways
that we're able to get people who are
much younger
and it's those younger people who can
also inform their parents and
other people within their community so
it's almost like creating a ripple
effect where
you let one person um understand the
importance of vaccination that will go
on and extend within itself
um and yeah so that's kind of where i
think it is i think
webinars talking to people within the
community going and talking to face
um faith groups as well but also just
remembering that
you and yourself you can actually
communicate and do research yourself and
then spread it on to other people near
you as well
keep it local just very quickly that's
what you've been discovering in your
reporting
yeah absolutely it is about those role
models it's about people hearing from
trusted sources the government in some
ways is doing some of that
public health england our troops we're
out of time thank you very much indeed
and thanks
to all my panel here for a most
illuminating
and informative conversation do stay
with us here on sky news
[Music]
you